this includes prioritizing publicly
funded pcr testing for high-risk
individuals who are symptomatic
and or are at increased risk of severe
illness from cova 19 including for the
purposes of confirming a covet 19
diagnosis to begin treatment
and workers and residents in the highest
risk settings as well as vulnerable
populations given how quickly the
omicron virus has spread we must
preserve these limited resources for
those who need them the most to make
these tests useful for clinical and for
public health decision making
ontario's supply of rapid antigen tests
remains limited at present
given this
global demand for these tests
and are being prioritized at present for
health care in high risk settings
however we are expanding and expecting
our additional supply over the next few
weeks to provide tests to other
prioritized settings so if you have
symptoms of coba 19 are not eligible for
pcr tests and do not have access to a
rapid antigen test you should assume
given the high community prevalence
that you have provide 19 you should stay
home and self isolate according to our
newest guidelines
as a reminder the isolation period is
now five days for those who are fully
vaccinated and experiencing symptoms
this also applies to their household
contacts
after five days if your symptoms have
resolved you may end your isolation
period but continue to wear a
well-fitted mask outside your home and
do not visit anyone who's
immunocompromised or visiting visit a
long-term care home retirement home or
hospital for at least 10 days from the
onset of your symptoms
if you have been exposed to someone who
has tested positive for coca-19 are
fully vaccinated have no symptoms
and not
a household contact
you must self-monitor for 10 days
instead of isolating
if you are unvaccinated or partially
vaccinated you must isolate for 10 days
along with your household contacts
please visit
ontario.ca forward slash
exposed
if you think or know you have been
exposed to covet 19 to access
information on what you can do to
protect yourself and your contacts
while most ontarians will not receive a
phone call from public health with
guidance on how to isolate i want to
encourage people to keep their eyes open
for texts
from the public health virtual assistant
these texts are not spam
they please provi uh take the time to
fill in the required information and it
will provide advice to you on your
self-isolation or monitoring period
i want to thank you all for your
continued sacrifices your tremendous
resilience and continued commitment to
protecting one another
from one wave to the next of this virus
this will be a tough january but i am
hopeful for a better february and a
brighter outlook moving into
march spring will bring relief but for
now we must continue to dig deep and
protect one another
until then
until the spring we are committed to
using every possible resource available
to protect ontario through this
difficult winter thank you and i'm
available to take questions
go to the phone lines for questions just
a reminder one question one follow-up
over to the first question please
from holly mckenzie suiter at the
canadian press please go ahead
hi uh in the rapid test update that we
just got with officials they confirmed
that
if somebody's able to take two tests uh
24 to 48 hours apart and then their
symptoms improve for
24 hours they don't have to isolate for
the full
five day period and i'm just wondering
how um
how that's
how to address the kind of inequity
created by that because some people can
afford to buy the test or have access
while others don't and i wouldn't be
able to go back to work school day care
anything like that as soon as others so
if you could just comment on that
well first in general there's a global
supply issue associated with uh rapid
androgen tests and we are doing our
utmost to provide more tests for
ontarians to be able to use them to
guide decision-making but given the high
level of community activity of omicron
across all communities in ontario if you
have symptoms so fever and or cough or
loss of taste or smell and or the minor
symptoms of nasal congestion
headache
muscle eggs joint eggs or fatigue or
weakness
that is enough at present to define
that you have covet 19. there are very
few other viruses circulating certainly
very little influenza
or rhinovirus activity at present so if
you have symptoms compatible with covet
19 please
you don't necessarily need a test to
confirm them
monitor your symptoms once they improve
and it's after five days and you're
significantly better you can return uh
to work
for health care workers in particular
we'd advise you to get a rat test for
day six and day seven just because
health care workers are working with
vulnerable populations cancer patients
transplant patients or in the long-term
care setting and we have to
provide the best level of protection in
those settings but after five days of
symptoms
alone um you are less infectious and
able to return to a normal workplace
where you're not working with vulnerable
patients
or clients
once we have our ats they will be able
to confirm
if you have a kovit 19 and one positive
rat test would confirm you don't need
anything else you do not need a pcr test
to confirm that you've got the illness
uh and you should follow the
instructions of the five days of
isolation 10 if you're unvaccinated or
immunocompromised
once we have access your your right but
there aren't many other viruses
circulating right now
but two negatives 24 hours apart would
allow you to return to
your work environment or your school
setting
our goal is to have these tests
as soon as possible for the school
setting where they would be used for
symptoms
and if it's a positive as we've said you
should stay home if it's two negatives
24 hours apart and your symptoms are
resolved you can return to the school
setting um we're doing our best to
increase the availability but at present
symptom monitoring given the high
community
level of activity of omicron is a very
good equivalent
paula
okay thank you yeah that didn't really
address the inequity question that
exists now because some people do have
rapid test access and therefore would
have a shorter isolation but i do have
another question about testing for uh
kids younger than five just because we
know this group is the only group of
people that can't be vaccinated they're
still going to group settings in daycare
um
and they aren't eligible for pcr tests
i'm just wondering um the rationale for
that and whether it might change
absolutely if we get increased
availability uh we will try to bring
back rat testing to that uh environment
the work we're doing in in that
environment in particular now is to
provide um an option for n95 non-fitted
mass to that workforce certainly we're
trying to accelerate a first second or
third doses to that workforce as well so
that the children are protected by not
having
vulnerable people to the virus are
working around them
and to continue all of the best
precautions the layered approaches for
masking hand hygiene screening on a
daily basis
for all the symptoms of the profit 19 if
you screen positive please stay home for
the full five days um
or until you're you're if it's more than
five days till your symptoms have
improved significantly all of those
measures that we put in play plus the
recommendations on improving ventilation
should work to continue to make those um
child care settings as safe as we can
make them uh and we are actively working
to get as many rats you may have heard
from the federal government uh that
they've procured additional tests for us
and we're awaiting the delivery of those
our framework though everyone in ontario
should realize is first use those rats
to keep our vulnerable settings safe so
our long-term care settings retirement
homes hospital sectors and other
congregate settings
and once we can maintain that safe
supply to ensure that patients are
protected
in those settings we will move down our
framework and provide them to be more
accessible and available and i'm sorry
the global supply is so limited but
we're your government is working
diligently to provide increased
availability of these tests
next question
yes hello so i just i was just wondering
dr moore if you could comment in french
about what you were saying about the
administration of third doses in the
education sector
um
with your permission stella i i continue
to take my french lessons and i don't
think i'm
fluent enough at present
but
our third dose strategy for workers is
to try to ensure that we can increase
the access for all child care workers
all staff
in education settings to be able to have
access for their third doses we're
working with school boards
with third parties that can provide
the immunization support we know our
health system partners our hospitals our
public health units are
fully active trying to immunize the
general population following our
guidelines so we're trying to provide
this additional resource to increase
access for staff in those settings to
get their third dose we're aiming to
have them up and running as you've heard
from the education announcement uh as
soon as possible um to provide uh the
level of protection um uh as we
further open our school settings um so
it's uh
all uh
aspects of the health system are working
diligently to try to protect uh the
staff in those environments
yes i had another question about rapid
tests
i was wondering what would you say to
someone who looks for example to do
who's trying to find
some rapid tests and see that there will
no longer be
some pop-up clinics uh on january 14 and
what do you say to to them so to people
who want to procure
some and are worried about that
first i'd say you know if if i come down
with the symptoms of clogged 19 so i get
a fever in a cough i'm not going to
seek any confirmatory testing i'm going
to stay at home for the five days and
hopefully my symptoms are resolved i
have had the benefit of receiving my
vaccines
and i will not seek any additional
testing right now given the high
community prevalence of covet 19.
testing is a luxury
monitoring your symptoms is what every
ontarian should be doing if you've got a
fever and or cough and or the minor
symptoms of nasal congestion headache
fatigue muscle aches and joint aches
that alone is has a high
probability of being coveted at present
given uh
over 600 per hundred thousand is our
current level of activity it's never
been so high uh it's never been so
prevalent in ontario uh if if we have
the luxury of testing absolutely um when
they're more available we'll provide
them uh first to those priority settings
like we've said uh if you'd like to have
uh your your symptoms
confirmed by a test uh those uh the
availability of them will be improved uh
in the coming weeks uh but really
symptom monitoring is what every
ontarian should be doing
if you develop the symptoms stay at home
we've done this prior for many other
viruses including influenza season
you stay at home when you're sick and
that decreases the transmission
and we've hitherto not had the benefit
of testing
the access and availability of testing
will improve but common sense should
prevail for every ontarian who develops
the symptoms of covet 19
consider those symptoms to be almost
diagnostic at present given uh how
prevalent it is in our community if your
symptoms deteriorate and you get more
short of breath or you get discomfort in
your chest
absolutely you should seek
health care
you should call your health care
provider seek guidance on whether you
need further assessment or if there are
severe symptoms absolutely would have to
visit a local emergency department
for those severe symptoms and get
assessed
but for the vast majority of ontarians
we'll be able to stay at home uh to take
uh tylenol or ibuprofen or fluids uh to
help us get over our symptoms and we'll
be better the vast majority will be
better we are so fortunate that with
omicron the severity of this illness is
less the risk of hospitalization is less
this is the first variant that's come
forward that has less impact potentially
on the hospital and healthcare system
and severity at an individual level
the only problem for our province is
it's so transmissible
so many of us are going to get it at a
very simultaneous period
that we've had to prepare the health
system for additional bed capacity if
necessary
next question
from rob ferguson at the toronto star
please go ahead
hi doctor with all the concern being
raised about capacity in the health care
system what what are your thoughts on
whether hospitals should be taking back
unvaccinated workers who were terminated
or otherwise suspended whatever
our policy at the government level was
to
ask every health care institution to
have an immunization policy that would
have
please provide us with your immunization
status and or if you haven't been
immunized
get educated if you choose further not
uh despite education to be immunized you
should have a testing strategy so many
hospitals have embraced that
immunization policy and continue to test
on immunization immunized workers and
have them in the workplace those that
and it's not the majority that adopted
mandatory immunization policies um have
had great success with that strategy in
that the vast majority of their workers
99
in many instances of health care
professionals in particular did go
forward and get immunized so they're not
having a significant burden uh on their
their workforce so i do believe the
immunization policy that the government
had recommended is working for ontarians
we do have the testing strategy and for
those individuals that did not get
vaccinated there at present in the face
of omicron will be getting tested on a
daily basis that's true where we asked
the immunization policies in other
settings outside of healthcare so in
other high-risk congregate settings
the immunize or test strategy still
exists
follow up
okay thank you doctor and and
i'm wondering uh what you think people
need to do more now i mean i think
there's a lot of regret in the province
that maybe some steps weren't taken
earlier than monday uh what do you think
people should be looking to as the next
steps
in getting omicron under better control
well thank you thank you robert uh just
to remind ontarians you've made
sacrifices all along so
on december
17th i believe we asked
that
facilities move to 50 capacity and we're
very reluctant to impose any public
health measures unless they're necessary
we also started our third dose strategy
on december 12th to further protect
ontarians uh in a very robust and
aggressive manner uh some days prior to
the holidays we were having 230 000
people immunized with their third dose
so ontarians
have come forward number one to get
boosted as well as have made the
sacrifices that we've asked decreased
capacity limits before christmas then we
stopped the large mass gathering venues
where we thought there could be ongoing
transmission and now in a timely phased
uh
and reluctantly uh have had to impose
these much more aggressive public health
measures our commitment to ontarians is
that we will only impose these for as a
time limited period that will maximize
the protection of the health system
that will continue to ensure that all
ontarians can receive care at the right
place at the right time
also with a directive that i've written
we are
again regrettably um stopping elective
surgeries for a defined period of time
that should give us 1200 to 1500
additional beds in which we can care for
ontarians if they need extra oxygen for
a short period of time we're also seeing
some good trends in that
when we monitor icu data certainly the
number of people in the intensive care
unit has gone up but their length of
stay is shortened so we're seeing it go
from 13 days in early december right now
down to six days that to me is a very
good trend that even though our numbers
are going up we're going to be able to
provide care
in the intensive care setting if it's
needed it will be a very difficult
january we will
reflect on whether we timed our
decisions appropriately given a very new
threat in
in this province of omicron
i take full responsibility for advising
government on these decisions i i hope
we've done
the right
decision making
i absolutely uh
am reluctant to
take away the freedoms of businesses and
individuals and to keep our schools
closed these are very difficult
difficult decisions to make
and i hope ontarians will
as usual
do their best in this very difficult
time to limit the spread of this virus
to come forward
to get their third doses this is crucial
that we increase our numbers i am in no
way uh happy at 180 000 doses a day i
would love us to
as as the threat increases in the coming
days to get more and more individuals
protected uh with the vaccine
and i trust all ontarians will continue
as we've done before to adhere to all
the best practices of masking of hand
hygiene and distancing i know this is a
tremendous sacrifice we've made
or asked ontarians to make in the coming
weeks
and i hope they'll understand it's so
that as a community we can face the
common enemy of this virus
and
we can together uh protect each other
in the coming days by all of us
adhering to these best practices i hope
um uh and indeed pray that um
we will be able to provide care to all
ontarians if and when we need
so thank you for that rob
next question
from colin demelo at ctv news please go
ahead
hi good afternoon dr moore i just wanted
to ask about the recent death of a child
under 10. all we know is that a
copigniting positive girl under 10 years
old died in wellington county are you
able to give us any more information on
this and what is being done differently
in ontario to treat young children with
the disease
oh colin i am
i'm taken aback i'm so sorry i wasn't
aware of of this death in that area of
the province
my heart goes out uh to to the family
and to the friends and i hope will give
the family the privacy uh to grieve and
to try
as best they can recover from the loss
of their child i'm very saddened to hear
it um uh as far as your your question um
the death of children is exceptionally
rare from this virus so i'm i am very
saddened to hear it um
these deaths
in general and and i don't want to give
any specifics would be fully
investigated by the attending physicians
uh they often are foreigner cases even
though it's a natural death from a known
virus
we want to learn as a system uh of
if there was any failings in the health
care system provide care
otherwise i want to assure all ontarians
that
we have
some of the world's best
pediatricians infectious disease experts
to be able to provide care to children
that we've only got a handful of
children in intensive care units across
ontario at present we're monitoring uh
their capacity
they have a only 70 of the beds in
intensive care unit today for children
are being used uh and we're not seeing a
significant rise in admissions um but um
we will uh colin you'll have our
assurance that we will learn uh from any
death of any child to try to ensure it
wasn't a failing of the health system
the failure to be able to provide care
that the child was provided as much care
as was possible at the time
and share lessons learned back typically
the coroner system shares it back
directly with the family
but to conclude uh
my my sincere condolences to the family
uh um on on their laws
i appreciate that thank you dr moore um
on another topic um you just said that
testing in ontario is a luxury obviously
because of the
low availability of tests and the high
demand but isn't isolating also a luxury
that certain segments of the working
population can't really afford um
is there a strategy being developed at
all for those part-time workers who
would find it very difficult to isolate
for five days at a time every time they
come down with symptoms is there some
kind of a strategy to maybe prioritize
those frontline part-time workers so
that they could also get either pcr
tests or rapid tests to ensure that they
could get back to work so that they
could you know put food in the table
well i hope a really good question
called colin thank you for it
i hope no one thinks i was being trite
by saying access to a test is a luxury
we are trying to provide increased
access and availability of testing in in
all provinces in canada
we are one of the highest providers of
rat testing at an individual level and
we'll try
giving the global supply chain to be
back uh able to be able to provide rat
testing my main point was if you have
symptoms of covid19 at present
you don't need an absolute confirmation
through tests given the high community
prevalence if you have a fever and a
cough
and or loss of taste or smell or those
minor symptoms that i previously
mentioned that correlates so strongly
with a high probability of you having
covid that you don't necessarily need
confirmation if you're vulnerable you've
got underlying medical conditions we
absolutely want you to get assessed and
we've created that list of priorities
for access to pcr testing
in emergency departments in hospitals
and long-term care or patients with
comorbidities those are our priority
populations to get confirmation testing
because that can guide our treatment it
can guide the isolation within a
hospital and ensure that others are
protected around you
so
the other aspect is
we have shortened the isolation period
from 10 days to five days following best
science if you're two dose vaccinated
and you are not immunocompromised
that was to decrease the burden of
isolation and ensure that if we if
someone could isolate it would have the
least impact on their livelihoods and i
do think five days is very reasonable to
be able to best protect others around
you that five days of isolation is then
followed by five days of masking in
public and your avoidance of
immunocompromised and not going to a
long-term care facility you're not
visiting your grandparents who may be
predisposed to this virus given that
your risk of viral shedding decreases
day after day day 6 7 8 9 10.
and i think that will work well in
ontario because as a community in
ontario all of us in public spaces and
in businesses should be masking and uh
providing a good hand hygiene distancing
uh and the monitoring and and trying to
improve the ventilation in any of those
environments so
i think this can work well i think it's
five days as realistic for two dose
vaccinated individuals and can minimize
the impact of the virus on on their
livelihood
certainly when we have increased access
to rats
that could give greater confidence that
they're providing isolation for the
appropriate reasons
last question
from carly weeks at the globe and mail
please go ahead
hi dr moore thanks for the um for taking
my question um i wanted to ask you had
mentioned uh in a previous briefing that
a more formal or final decision on
vaccines for children born 2017 would be
coming um just wanted to know if some
any decision has been reached
well thank you carly uh they are
vigorously debating it at the ontario
immunization advisory committee uh and
they haven't uh reached a conclusion so
as of today it's still by date of birth
that you'd be eligible uh for
vaccination turning five um today you'd
be eligible uh for your vaccination uh
and i'm sorry the booking system uh
is getting fixed to ensure that we have
a you can't book if you're four
and haven't turned five so um that that
would be fixed in the coming days uh but
just so individuals won't go to
immunization clinic expecting to be
immunized if you're not five they
for the most part
unless there's a off-label decision by a
health care provider will not receive
the vaccine
follow-up and this is the last question
great yeah so you had mentioned that
there is a plan in place to return to
school january 17th um there's a number
of things that you mentioned have been
done like um more filters and and 95s
for staff things like that uh is it
realistic though to expect children will
be back in class given the explosion in
case numbers anything more you can you
can share is that a realistic timeline
well the the opening of schools
certainly is a decision of government i
i think we all understand that there's
negatives and positives to keeping our
schools closed uh and i i like all of my
colleagues in public health uh hope uh
that we can have our children back in
for in-person learning as soon as
possible so in the interim
despite that aspirational goal and with
that aspirational goal we are
further immunizing first second and
third doses for the staff of child care
and in education
we are further providing first and
second doses to children five to eleven
we're further purchasing additional
n95
and high grade mass for children where
three thousand additional hepa filters
have been purchased and we're
interested in putting those in in play
as soon as possible
and we're viewing all of our guidelines
uh to ensure we're keeping up
to
the standard on protecting our schools
as well as reviewing all environmental
health cleaning and ventilation
standards so that works getting done um
we're working in the background
i think all students want to be back in
in class all parents would love them in
class
and we're working with the education
sector to ensure our schools remain as
safe as possible that is our goal um but
the eventual decision of this is the
decision of government um
and it's certainly uh our hope that we
can adhere to the 17th
thanks everyone
you